From his humble start as a stand-out performer
in the '90s sketch comedy show In Living Color,
Jim Carrey has been one of the hottest comedians
in Hollywood.
With memorable starring roles in Ace Ventura,
The Mask, Batman Forever, and Dumb & Dumber...
"Wanna hear the most annoying sound in the
world?
Ahhh!"
...Carrey proved himself as one of the best
physical comedians of the 1990s.
Even his turns in dramatic roles, like The
Truman Show and Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless
Mind were met with huge critical success.
But whether you've enjoyed him in big-budget
comedies or surreal dramas, for some reason
he's been seen on screen less and less in
recent years.
So, why won't Hollywood won't cast Jim Carrey
anymore?
Box office confusion
Back in the day, Carrey's films were surefire
box office hits, but his more recent films
have been less of a guarantee.
His more critically acclaimed films don't
make a ton of money, and his most profitable
films aren't very well-loved.
While Dumb and Dumber To performed well at
the box office, earning about $130 million
over its budget, reviews were unkind.
And non-franchise films, like The Incredible
Burt Wonderstone and I Love You Phillip Morris,
weren't financially successful, with Wonderstone
losing $3 million amid negative reviews, and
Phillip Morris only making a $7 million profit,
despite largely positive reviews.
Studios want a star with a predictable box
office draw before betting on a big-budget
film.
Despite his talents, no one can be sure if
the next Carrey film will lay an egg.
He's not winning awards
By the early 2000s, Carrey earned four Golden
Globe nominations and two wins in a short
period of time…
"You know, when I go to sleep at night, I'm
not just a guy going to sleep.
I'm two-time Golden Globe winner Jim Carrey
going to get some well-needed shut-eye."
But unfortunately, he hasn't been nominated
for a major award since 2004's Eternal Sunshine
of the Spotless Mind.
And even though there was some critical buzz
for I Love You Phillip Morris, he missed out
on all the major ceremonies.
Carrey's biggest major awards recognition
since then was a Razzie nomination for worst
actor in The Number 23.
Razzie-winning actors have turned it around
before, but they're not always exactly what
casting directors are looking for.
Controversial beliefs
Since his relationship with Jenny McCarthy,
Carrey has been vocal about his stance on
vaccines, which he's called "poison," and
referred to pro-vaccine California governor
Jerry Brown as a "corporate fascist" who "must
be stopped."
While he's entitled to his personal beliefs,
it can be risky for a studio to go with an
actor who could alienate audiences with his
political comments, especially those relating
to public health.
In addition to that, Carrey spoke out against
his own film, Kick Ass 2, in 2013, after coming
to the realization that the ultra-violent
comic movie made him uncomfortable because
of recent school shootings.
Again, speaking out for your beliefs admirable,
but this particular stand wasn't something
that the studio's promotional tour managers
probably wanted to hear.
It wouldn't be surprising if other studios
took notice.
Lawsuit trouble
As of the making of this video, Carrey is
fighting against wrongful death suits filed
by the mother and ex-husband of his former
girlfriend Cathriona White, who died of an
intentional drug overdose in 2015.
White's family alleges that Carrey knowingly
gave their daughter sexually transmitted diseases,
lied to her, threatened her, gave her the
drugs she overdosed on, and then broke up
with her to protect his public image.
Carrey responded in a statement, saying,
"I will not tolerate this heartless attempt
to exploit me or the woman I loved."
He further called the allegations "irrelevant,
false and improper," and a "shameless shakedown
for money."
It's entirely possible that Carey's free time
might be getting sucked up by dealing with
putting these lawsuit issues behind him.
Behind the camera
More recently, Carrey has been spending more
time behind the camera, working as the creator
and executive producer of the Showtime series
I'm Dying Up Here.
The series draws from Carrey's experiences
as a stand-up comic, starring Melissa Leo
as the owner of a comedy club in the 1970s.
Carrey doesn't act in the show, but he's been
actively promoting the project and working
on it behind the scenes.
And Carrey seems like he's pretty happy with
life away from the spotlight, saying during
a press panel at the Television Critics Association
that he's...
"...in the process of shedding layers of persona
at this time in my life.
… I'm very happy to [be] here for these
guys and watch these guys enter this world
and create these characters."
How he can turn it around
For Carrey, the secret to turning his career
around could lie in returning to the small
screen.
His appearance on 30 Rock and The Office made
waves...
"I want the job.
I really do.
It's just the rest of my family is in the
Finger Lakes right now.
I'm supposed to be in the Finger Lakes right
now."
...so it's clear that if he doesn't have the
box-office bang required to sell a blockbuster
anymore, there's plenty of room to return
to TV, where he could be a big fish in a smaller
pond.
Who wouldn't want to see Jim Carrey in a regular
role on TV again?
Like many stars, a hit show could help revitalize
his career, and maybe even lead him back to
bigger movie roles in the future.
"Hey!
Take a leap, pal."
"THAT'S THE SPIRIT!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!